if you want to strip that off your body
there is nothing no type of
cardiovascular or weight training that
comes anywhere close to
spend 20 years working in life insurance
predicting when people were going to die
to the nearest month and now he's on a
mission to extend your life most people
if they're walking around right now at
about 55 of their true state of normal
there is an element missing from their
body that would make the difference
between them being an average person and
being a superhuman how
everything that we put into our bodies
gets converted into the usable form if
you cannot make this conversion you have
a deficiency and it is this deficiency
that leads to these conditions they have
accepted something as either a
consequence of Aging stress or their
environment this is not a consequence of
any of those things I'm going to tell
you exactly how to find out what it is
that's missing so you could thrive in a
way that you probably never thought
possible let's use Dana White as an
example so LabCorp calls us so it says
hey we have a life-threatening alert on
a patient he had all of these conditions
I've been talking to doctors none of
them could fix any of my problems I said
I'm surprised you can even sleep through
the night without choking gagging he's
like slammed his hand down how did you
know that and I said if you don't do
what we're going to ask you to do if you
have a life expectancy at 10.4 years and
in 10 weeks he has such a material
change and he was like I had no idea I
could feel this good and his life
expectancy almost tripled someone who's
just heard that at home where do they
start so
I just want to start this episode with a
message of thanks a thank you to
everybody that Tunes in to listen to
this podcast by doing so you've enabled
me to live out my dream but also for
many members of our team to live out
their dreams too it's one of the
greatest privileges I could never have
dreamed of or imagined in my life to get
to do this to get to learn from these
people to get to have these
conversations to get to interrogate them
from a very selfish perspective trying
to solve problems I have in my life so I
feel like I owe you a huge thank you for
being here and for listening to these
episodes and for making this platform
what it is can I ask you a favor I can't
tell you how much you can change the
course of this podcast the the course of
the guests we're able to invite to the
show and to the course of everything
that we do here just by doing one simple
thing and that simple thing is hitting
that subscribe button helps this channel
more than I could ever explain the
guests on this platform are incredible
because so many of you have hit that
button and I know when we think about
what we want to do together over the
next year on this show a lot of it is
going to be fueled by the amount of you
that are subscribed in that tune in to
this show every week so thank you let's
keep doing this and I can't wait to see
what this year brings for this show for
us as a community and for this platform
foreign
[Music]
yes
I this is the first time I've started
this podcast in this particular way but
I was but this is where I wanted to
start it it's with a slightly curious
question which is
there's people that have just clicked
onto this podcast to listen now right
YouTube Spotify Apple wherever they're
listening
um why should they
stay and listen to the message that you
have committed your life to spreading
because everybody wants to be better
right I mean everybody wants to improve
their health and most people especially
young people
probably don't realize that they're
walking around right now at about 55
maybe 60 percent of their true state of
normal
there is
a nutrient an amino acid a substrate a
compound
an element missing from their body that
if they knew what it was
would make the difference between them
being an average person and being a
superhuman they have accepted something
as either a consequence of Aging or a
consequence of stress or a consequence
of their environment something like
brain fog or repeated poor sleep or
weight gain or water retention or not
the healthiest response to exercise or
brain fog or poor short-term recall or
any number of things that they've
accepted as consequence of Life of Aging
of stress or what have you that's not a
consequence of any of those things it's
a consequence of missing raw material
and I'm going to describe that in detail
and tell you exactly how to put that raw
material back into your body
and how to find out what it is that's
missing so you could thrive in a way
that you've probably never thought
possible who are you
um I'm a human biologist
um and a researcher biohacker my
background is in of all things mortality
science you know my undergraduate
degrees were in biology my postgraduate
degrees are in human biology I'm
fascinated by the human body it's form
it's function how we can improve its
performance and
I'm a researcher you know I spent 22
years
um as a mortality expert in the
insurance industry which meant that if
we got five years of demographic data on
you and five years of medical records we
could tell the insurance company how
long you had to live to the month to the
month to the month and I get a lot of
flack about that people say oh if you
can predict death to the month you'd win
a Nobel Prize or you know only God can
tell you when you're going to die I mean
and that's very true I mean obviously if
we do a mortality prediction on it
doesn't mean December 12th you know 2065
you're going to drop that on that day
but it is very accurate science you know
if you think of the most successful
financial institutions on the planet as
a category are insurance companies if
you look at the failures during the
2008-2009 financial crisis which was a
global crisis you know in the U.S we had
364 Banks fail you didn't have a single
life insurance company fail no other
financial institution no other
investment Enterprise hedge fund angel
investor
um Venture Capital firm would ever put
tens of millions of dollars at risk on
any kind of investment on one single
variable
yet every time a life insurance company
bets on your life or or issues an
annuity or a reverse mortgage or any
number of other Financial Services
instruments that are based on mortality
they're only betting on one factor they
don't care where you are on a mortality
curve they want to know how many more
months does this person have left on
Earth and it is some of the most
accurate science on the planet
and they have perfected this and the
good news is that the science is very
accurate and I'm going to share a lot of
the details of that today but the
downside of this industry and the reason
why I left it was that during my tenure
in this career
I was not allowed to have any contact
with the patient or any contact with the
treating physician now I'm not licensed
to practice medicine I'm a human
biologist
but if I was reading a medical record
and saw a life-threatening drug
interaction I could not contact the
patient
and this database where this information
is drawn from if this database could see
the light of day
I believe it would permanently change
the face of humanity it would upend
modern medicine in a way that would be
completely catastrophic because you see
they have information that no other
database has no other research study no
other financial institution no other
university has and that is that they
know the day the date the time the
location and the cause of death for
hundreds of millions of people that they
have all of these records on
you know if I'm a cardiologist and you
come in to see me and I put a heart
stent in your heart when you leave my
office I don't know what happens to you
two months later two years later 12
years later I don't know if you died as
a consequence of something that went
wrong with the procedure I did or if you
died of something completely different I
don't know exactly what kind of impact
on your life that procedure had or
didn't have unless it's contained in a
very short-term clinical study and not
that I want to go into the whole science
of mortality but
if you had access to this database you
would realize that the most common
ailments that we suffer from
are not diseases and pathology that are
happening to us they are things that are
happening within us
you know I always say that if I was to
boil my entire career down to a single
sentence it would be that the presence
of oxygen is the absence of disease
and nothing is more impactful than that
statement
the presence of oxygen is the absence of
disease I have yet defined a single
disease ideological pathway something
that's happening in in the human body
causing pathology causing disease
dysfunction that doesn't have its roots
in a lack of blood oxygen or its roots
is not aggravated by something called
hypoxia lack of oxygen in fact all human
beings die of the same thing we all
leave this earth the same way right we
all die of hypoxia lack of oxygen to the
brain that's the definition of death
Only We tend to think of it as an event
right a gunshot wound a bus car a stroke
heart attack but the truth is we are on
a hypoxic curve
meaning we are accelerating quickly or
accelerating slowly towards the grave
and the second thing that we discovered
in this
voluminous data-driven industry was that
when you deplete certain raw materials
in the human body
you get the expression of that
deficiency so what I mean is you know
we've all heard that
um uh disease you know travels in
families or you might have genetically
inherited hypertension or genetically
inherited hypothyroid genetically
inherited drug and alcohol addiction
diabetes
um depression anxiety these things tend
to run in families so we've accepted the
myth in most cases that these are
genetically inherited diseases but think
about this the next time one of your
listeners gets told that oh you have
genetically inherited hypertension what
we call uh
idiopathic hypertension or genetically
inherited hypothyroid or if you have
this genetically inherited disease or
that genetically inherited disease stop
your physician and say well wait a
minute we've mapped the entire human
genome
um so we know every Gene in the human
body can you tell me what disease I
inherited from my ancestor that's
actually causing this condition
and watch their face go blank
because in the majority of cases we have
accepted that disease travels in
families when it's actually not the
disease being passed from generation to
generation it is the inability for their
body to refine a certain raw material
which causes a deficiency which leads to
that disease
so in other words there's not a single
compound known to mankind not one no
mineral vitamin amino acid protein
carbohydrate no nutrient of any kind no
element known to man that enters the
human body and is used in the format
that we put it in everything that we put
into our bodies gets taken in by the
body and converted into the usable form
you cannot make this conversion
you have a deficiency and it is this
deficiency that leads to these
conditions
and so if you go hunting for that
deficiency and you supplement not for
the sake of supplementing but you
supplement for the sake of deficiency
magic things happen in human beings
there is a superhuman inside of every
person listening to this podcast and if
they actually were able to test
themselves to a genetic test and look at
what's called their methylation how
their body refines raw materials and
they were able to replace the deficiency
that is holding their body back from
creating adequate levels of
neurotransmitter and achieving normal
mood moving
contents through the gut and achieving
normal gut function elevating emotional
state deepening their sleep quieting
their mind all of these conditions that
Society has labeled different
pathologies and disease
then they would begin to thrive in a way
that they just never thought possible
it so blatantly clear how passionate you
are about this subject matter which begs
the question you know I remember when I
was reading through your story
I I uncovered that you'd read hundreds
of peer-reviewed papers I think the
quote was something along the lines of
um if there's a peer-reviewed paper on
the subject matter of biohacking and
um disease and Longevity and those kinds
of things you've basically read it so
this begs the question to me like why is
one individual so unbelievably
passionate about this subject matter and
I would like you to take me as early as
you possibly can to answer that question
in your own life where did your
obsession passion where was it fostered
fostered and nurtured so that you've
spent and committed your life to this
subject matter where did that begin
so it actually began I I grew up on a
very large tobacco farm my father was a
Navy captain my mom was a flight
attendant she worked for the airlines
but we had a a farm that we leased out
to other farmers and surrounding this
300 acre tobacco farm were all kinds of
Animal Farms or cattle Farms or chicken
farms there was horse farms and I was an
only child my nearest neighbor was Miles
Away in fact from my home you couldn't
even see another house from my parents
house until I was in my early 20s
and so for me to to play with another
child I had to get on a bike and spend
half an afternoon biking to their house
so I got very familiar with the farm and
I was always just fascinated
by the veterinarians that would come
onto these farms and fix horses and fix
cattle and fix sheep and fix chickens
and I always thought it was so cool that
these animals could be laying on the
ground seemingly about to die and the
veterinarian would come come on board
and do a bunch of stuff and the next
thing you know this horse was up and a
few days later it was Galloping back in
the field or you had
all kinds of strange things that would
happen on this farm and there was always
someone arriving to just fix it and I
started to get fascinated with medicine
I guess in that way I always found it as
a way to take something that was sick
and helpless and sort of help it get
back to normal function and I found out
in the eighth grade sometime during my
eighth grade year that I was clinically
photographic
so I have a clinical level photographic
recall which is different than just
having a visual memory I'm clinically
photographic so I have a voluminous
capacity to recall things that I read
even if I don't understand them which is
why I never read for pleasure I'm very
cautious about what I read I'm very
cautious about what I look at because I
record everything so I can't be flying
on American Airlines and take the seat
back magazine out and read the CPAC
magazine because
three months later I'll tell you where
the sales Center is for a condo project
in Buenos Aires you know so I can I can
fill my brain with senseless things like
that and record it and regurgitate it or
I can fill it full of things that that
fascinate me and so I naturally
gravitated towards science is that what
they call a photograph photographic
memory photographic memory is usually
someone that can remember seven numbers
in sequence they have extremely good
recall for things that they visualize
clinically photographic is being able to
regurgitate voluminous amounts of
information with Incredible accuracy so
I still remember you know section 15 2
so paragraph B of my first Employment
contract that I signed 28 years ago
really um really yeah I remember I
remember that it was actually with the
trading firm
um that I signed it with so
you know when I read peer-reviewed
papers
um in scientific journals uh it doesn't
make me more intelligent than someone
because very often I can recall
information that I don't understand so I
can regurgitate luminous amounts of
information so subjects that rely on
rote memorization like chemistry biology
neurobiology microbiology a lot of these
Sciences don't actually make sense right
that you just have to memorize how they
operate chemistry in a lot of ways
doesn't make sense right you just have
to remember what happens when you put
these two elements together they create
this or you know when you pull a carbon
Bond or you double a carbon Bond here or
hydrogen bond there that you that the
molecule shifts in this way and so I
gravitated towards science I got my
undergraduate degree in biology how did
you do
um I did very well I actually found it
quite the breeze um my you know when I
was an undergrad my you know biology
chemistry were considered the toughest
majors and I went to Branch campus
University of Maryland a lot of my
roommates were political science not
investing on political science majors at
all or philosophy or psychology and they
got to party all the time and you know I
had
really intense classes you know
morphology of phthalophytes and
chemistry and and you know biomechanics
and and Science and and a lot of plant
biology courses and human biology
courses but I was able to have the same
kind of social life that they were
because I would you know record a
lecture and then I would regurgitate the
lecture when I needed it during during a
test is it a gift or a cuss because with
all things in life that appear to be
gifts there's often some kind of hidden
curse well the curse is that I can't I
rarely read for pleasure
um it's very difficult to read for
pleasure because I record all of that
information so when I'm going in to read
a book you know a lot of people read a
book that they didn't really like it
doesn't stay with them
um or they read a fiction novel doesn't
really give them any benefit it's not
doesn't doesn't feed them but they do it
to relax or they do it for entertainment
for me it would take up storage
I know I I would record that information
so there's no need for me to have that
information in my possession I I find
other ways to to relax and and and
meditate and unwind but reading for
pleasure just just not one of them so I
guess that could be a curse but you know
then I went to grad school for human
biology I went to another four years of
school for human biology so I had eight
years of Science and then I was
um either going to go into Chiropractic
or into orthopedic medicine I really
like the idea of Orthopedics because
again an orthopedic surgeon was somebody
that fixed people and
you know an internist was somebody that
just managed disease you know they took
up obese hypertensive diabetic uh
patient and they just kind of managed
their case throughout their lifetime but
I felt like an orthopedic was somebody
that you know you came in and you had a
broken leg and they
you know fixed your broken leg and and
you were back to normal I like the idea
of fixing things and then kind of
returning function back to people and I
took some time off you know after I got
my human biology degree and I ended up
going into a rare area of science
um this mortality science
um for life insurance and secondary Life
Insurance
where you would take medical records and
demographic data and you would use this
in what's called a probabilistic model
to predict life expectancy and I was
fascinated by it because I love the Big
Data nature of it and for years I
actually subscribed to the fact that
this was just data
and that
I had no influence on this person's
outcome I didn't put them in his
position nor am I responsible for
getting them out of this position
but eventually I think as both my faith
grew and my awareness of the fact that
there were human beings on the other
side of these spreadsheets
I finally made a conscious decision to
say what am I doing I'm going to spend
the rest of my life just predicting
death
um for the monetary gain
of an investor
versus taking this information and
helping people live healthier happier
longer more fulfilling lives because by
studying medical records and you know
hybrid you know eight to ten hours a day
six days a week thousands and thousands
and thousands of medical records and
extracted from those how it would impact
somebody's outcome
of their life you know how how it would
impact the length of or the shortness of
the duration of their life their health
span or their lifespan and once you
realize there's human beings on the
other side of the spreadsheet you start
to feel like you're sitting behind a
thick glass wall just watching blind
people walk into traffic
and towards the tail end I used to
artificially kind of manipulate the
record I would say well what if I what
if I artificially fixed this person's D3
deficiency what if I cured the anemia
what if I actually
um noticed that they had a gene mutation
called MTHFR instead of trying to fix
them with folic acid I fixed them with
methylfolate and you would just see the
life expectancy jump in the model in the
model yeah right and this model was
based on very large data so it was very
likely to have a real life impact and
when I say we predicted death to the
month it was based on that patient's
current position and it doesn't mean
that they couldn't walk out the the next
day and and get hit by a bus or die in a
commercial airline you know disaster or
something like that but there's there
were standard deviations that would
account for those kinds of risks what
insurance company wanted to quantify or
the annuity company the reverse mortgage
company wanted to quantify was based on
this person's everything that we know
about this person right now the function
of their liver the slightly hypoxic
anemic profile that they have the
deficiencies that they have in vitamin
D3 they suppressed immune system
um you know the elevated visceral fat
the body mass index the bone mineral
density based on all of these things
when do these things all meet
and actually cause a catastrophic event
catastrophic event and there were things
called mortality debits and comorbidity
debits and we put all these together and
I really like the data of it but
realizing that there were human beings
on the other side of the spreadsheet
just woke me up and I said you know I
have this
Chasm of knowledge even though I'm not a
physician I have a fundamental
understanding of human physiology I'm
fascinated by human physiology and ways
that we can improve
lifespan and health span
and so why wouldn't I take this
gift and get into an industry like
wellness or functional medicine where I
could actually make a difference where
instead of predicting death we could
extend life
and in doing so help people if healthier
happier longer lives more fulfilling
lives get rid of a lot of the ailments
that people suffer from I mean when you
when you start to peel back the way that
modern medicine defines a lot of
conditions that we have you know take um
depression or anxiety or add or ADHD
because a lot of your listeners are
probably entrepreneurs and a lot of
entrepreneurs have very active minds and
they've been told they have attention
deficit disorder right or temperature in
deficit hyperactivity disorder well an
intention deficit disorder is not an
attention deficit at all
um we misdefined these things it's an
attention overload disorder because you
see in the human brain we don't just
create thought we also dismantle thought
it is just as important for you to be
able to create a new thought or feeling
as it is to dismantle it right and if
you don't degrade thought called
catecholamines if you don't degrade them
then there's a gene that governs this
catecholomethyl transferase if you
create thought at a faster rate than you
degrade thought then the mind gets very
clouded and so attention deficit
disorder is attention overload disorder
it's too many windows open at the same
time so modern medicine says well if the
mind's racing let's put an amphetamine
into the body race the central nervous
system to match the pace of the mind and
this is a very poor choice right because
eventually this will burn you out it can
actually change the neuroplasticity of
the brain rather than put the right
amino acids back into the body the right
B complex blend the right methylated
folates so that the mind can actually
begin to quiet what would you say to
someone that says that ADHD is also in
some ways a result of some early trauma
well you know trauma was always
fascinating to me trauma can trigger
methylation trauma can interrupt the
methylation cycle
right but the the idea in modern
medicine that you have some kind of
trauma you have a disrupted relationship
with your mother for example and that
somehow we're going to go and put
neuroplasticity altering chemicals into
the brain it's going to fix this 30-year
broken relationship you have with your
mother to me it doesn't yeah make any
sense right and so it's not at all to
poo poo trauma to to put trauma down
depression really exists anxiety really
exists but but if you actually look at
how we Define these conditions take
depression for example we Define
depression at least in America we Define
oppression as an inadequate supply of
Serotonin right so if you are low in
serotonin you're by definition depressed
so then you would think that the
solution would be to raise serotonin
right if we Define depression as low
serotonin you think the solution will be
an erased serotonin but that's not what
we do we take people that are depressed
and we put them on ssris selective
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors and what
these do is they ration what little
serotonin these people have so by
definition it never raises serotonin so
by definition it never ends depression I
mean I've I've clients come in to see me
all the time and and and on our clinical
team and then I'll say well how long
have you been on antidepressants say 15
years 18 years and my first question is
when did you think it was going to kick
in
right so if we understand that serotonin
is actually methylated in the gut this
process that I'm talking about is called
methylation we actually make serotonin
from an amino acid called tryptophan the
one that's famous for making you sleepy
after Thanksgiving dinner I know you
guys don't have Thanksgiving in the UK
but
um from America but
um so because we eat a lot of turkey on
Thanksgiving and turkey has a lot of
tryptophan so when you take um
tryptophan methylated into the
neurotransmitter serotonin of which 90
resides in your gut methylate is
basically process yeah the processing
it's like the refining process crude oil
gets refined into gasoline amino acids
get methylated into neurotransmitters
and so this process of methylation
when it's broken and and it can be
relatively easy to fix when it's broken
it means that we have an impaired
ability to create we have an impaired
ability to
um refine a raw material and it leads to
this deficit well serotonin for example
90 of it resides in your gut so if you
don't have it here you can't have it
here so depression rarely begins in the
outside environment it usually begins in
the gut now it may be trauma that led to
the deficiency but the fix is not in a
chemical or synthetic or pharmaceutical
blocking the brain's capacity to uptake
these neurotransmitters the fix is in
restoring adequate levels to the body so
we can naturopathically make its way
back up the vagus nerve and and arrive
to the brain similar things are true
with anxiety I mean if you actually have
ever suffered from or know somebody who
suffered from anxiety if you ask them
three questions you can find out very
quickly that their anxiety is not coming
from a cluster of symptoms it's not
coming from their outside environment it
is coming from within them it's coming
from their physiology right I mean if
you know someone who's suffered from
anxiety and you say well have you had
anxiety on and off throughout your
lifetime
the most of the time they'll say yes and
then if you say can you point to the
specific trigger that causes it
very often they'll say no
I mean yes I know some of my triggers
but I could be sitting in a podcast just
like this in a very calm environment
there's no threats around it all of a
sudden I get overwhelmed by anxiety I
can be driving home from work on an
otherwise innocuous day and I can be
overwhelmed by anxiety well that is not
coming from your outside environment
right this is coming from a process
called methylation and it is caused from
excess catecholamines entering the brain
and an inability to down regulate these
so the body's entering this mild
fight-or-flight response without the
presence of a fear
so you remember that as sophisticated as
we like to think our brains are it's
really not our brain is very Primal you
know what the brain cares about the
brain cares about survival
and so doesn't care how fat or skinny
you are how pretty or
ugly you are it doesn't care about your
skin your hair cares about survival and
so when we understand that the brain
does not know the difference between
perception and reality we start to
understand how we can play tricks on us
so I always use the example that let's
say you drove home tonight
and you got out of your car when you got
home you got out of your car and
somebody was standing in front of you
with a knife
it's a very real threat right you'd have
a fight or flight response your pupils
would dilate your heart rate would
increase your extremities would flood
with blood your hearing would get very
acute your brain would flood with
catecholamines you are getting ready to
fight or flight
but you could also be laying on the 30th
floor of a Condo building in bed and
start thinking about getting eaten by a
shark
there is zero chance of a shark getting
out of the ocean going up a 30th floor
elevator right coming into your condo
and biting you in that bed but you can
have the exact same response if you're
watching a movie or something you
exactly so one is entirely real one is
entirely perceived the physiologic
response is identical
once we understand this now we begin to
understand how I can feel the presence
of a fear which is what anxiety is it's
a fear of something happening in the
future usually it's not going to happen
usually hasn't happened in the past and
is not likely to happen but it's it's
this fear starts to build up you start
to get very anxious it can actually
change your heart rate
um to the point where you can panic
attacks can land you in a hospital or it
can be mild enough that it just causes
you anxiousness and Mild anxiety but
there's no presence of a fear and so you
start trying to correlate it to your
outside environment starts to drive you
crazy because you go well I don't get it
I'm on vacation with my wife or my
spouse and my kids and I'm in the resort
of a lifetime I've been here a thousand
times I love this place there's no
reason I should feel like this but all
of a sudden you have this feeling of
anxiousness anxiety so these are these
are lack of raw material in the human
body my mission is to try to help people
by taking a genetic test
um once in their lifetime find out where
is methylation broken and then stop
supplementing just for the sake of
supplementing and start supplementing
for this deficiency so your body can
thrive in the case of people that are
listening to this now and they can
pinpoint the moments where they've
gotten anxiety so say they've I remember
I had one guest on the podcast maybe two
years ago
and after he became famous he developed
social anxiety so he whenever he would
be with around a lot of people he would
feel that sense of anxiety and then from
that sort of catalystic moment then when
he's at home he'd get the same Rush of
anxiety but he would point to that
catalystic moment of becoming famous and
then some things had happened in his
life and then he'd get anxiety at home
when nothing was going on right in that
situation what's the news so there you
go so so now you've you've you've
interrupted methylation because there's
one where there is the presence of fear
and there's one where there isn't
there's the absence of a fear so to be
very specific anxiety true anxiety does
exist but you can point to the specific
trigger that causes it so for example if
you if you have a fear of heights and
you walk to the edge of a 30th floor
balcony and look over you're gonna feel
anxiety yeah if you're claustrophobic
and you step on a really crowded
elevator you're going to feel anxiety
but if you're claustrophobic and you're
sitting at home
and you start to become overwhelmed with
anxiety yeah this is actually not coming
from that trigger this is coming from
your physiology and the way that we deal
with stress right and like cortisol when
you measure cortisol levels cortisol is
not really a measure of how much stress
is in your life it's a measure of your
body's reaction to stress so why are
some people more resilient to stress and
don't have anxiety attacks and why are
other people not as resistant again this
is not to say that if you didn't have a
violent attack in your life or or a
terrible car accident that sometimes
when you've had a you know a vehicle
accident you approach an intersection
the the the memory of having been
T-boned you know recently and badly
injured is going to give you anxiety but
the majority of people are not suffering
from that type of hyperspecific
situational anxiety they're suffering
from something called generalized
anxiety or idiopathic anxiety which
means of Unknown Origin so for somebody
who's very famous
and gets into a a crowd and doesn't know
who's coming at them that's a very I
wouldn't even Define that as anxiety
that's a very Primal instinctual
reaction to a real fear right just like
walking to the edge of a 30th floor
balcony what's not a primal reaction to
a real fear is when there is no presence
of a fear especially if that incident
has never happened and you aren't even
sure what you are afraid of or why you
are anxious or why you have anxiety Then
this is coming from your physiology so
how would you treat that you look at the
different uh there are five major
actionable genes that I like to look at
in there what's it called their
sub-alleals and when you find out what
they're deficient in you start to
supplement with things like Sam e s
adenosol methionine methylated forms of
vitamins LMA thionine the the proper
balance of B complex
methylated forms of folic acid or folate
called methylfolate and what happens is
now the body has the capacity to degrade
these neurotransmitters that are causing
this fight or flight this group of
neurotransmitters called catecholamines
and the anxiousness that follows and
you'll find that the majority of people
that suffer from idiopathic anxiety or
generalized anxiety because of low
serotonin they also have gut issues
um you show me a person that's truly
depressed and I'll show you somebody
that's also suffering from severe gut
issues either gas or bloating or
diarrhea constipation irritability
cramping because the same
neurotransmitters that affect these
emotional states also are responsible
for the motility of the gut the speed of
the gut this is the most overlooked
thing in all of bariatric medicine
because
people that believe that they have all
of these allergies well I'm allergic to
wheat soy corn Dairy blueberries bananas
you know gluten
yes sometimes those individual allergies
do exist but the majority of time even
if you talk to somebody who says yeah I
I get bloated or I deal with gas or
cramping or diarrhea or constipation or
irritability I deal with all of these
gut issues irritable bowel syndrome uh
Crohn's disease ulcerative colitis all
these names that we give to conditions
of the gut when you ask them well what
are you allergic to
and they give you this laundry list of
things and then you ask them another
question and say well if you're really
allergic to corn
is there ever a time that you can eat
corn and not have a reaction the
majority of time people will say yes
okay well right there you know you don't
have an allergy allergies are not
transient allergies are consistent right
you don't wake up Monday morning and
being allergic to milk and then you're
unallergic on Wednesday afternoon and
then re-allergic on Saturday morning but
what happens when people have gut issues
that they can't explain is they always
correlate it to what they last ate and
it's hard to make this connection
they're like wait a second I ate the
same thing Monday and I was fine and I
ate the identical food on Wednesday and
I blew up like a tick so this is not
analogy this has to do with the motility
of the gut so if you don't know what
gene mutation you have that is causing a
deficiency then you don't know what to
supplement with to restore gut motility
but once you do the gut goes back to its
normal Pace what's gut motility it's the
pace of the gut so if you remember Henry
Ford was actually not made famous for
the automobile he was made famous for
something called the assembly line so
the assembly line was just a glorified
conveyor belt right and when you walked
into his Factory they put a part on it
at one end and about every six feet
somebody stood and tinkered with that
part so it went to me I tinkered with it
and moved to the guy to my right he did
something to it moved to the guy to his
right and by the time it reached the end
of that conveyor belt it's fully
assembled this is very analogous to how
the human intestinal tract works
it's 30 feet long it's a giant conveyor
belt you put parts on it at one end as
they exit the stomach in a very acidic
environment and it moves slowly towards
the rectum and before it exits the
rectum it's in a relatively alkaline
environment so instead of having people
standing along a conveyor belt you have
bacteria that are graded by pH
the sequence is very important
so imagine what would happen if Henry
Ford walked into his Factory one day and
doubled the speed of the conveyor belt
the entire assembly line would break
down not because there's anything wrong
with the parts the contents not because
there's anything wrong with the people
that are working there the bacteria but
because you change the speed what if he
went in there one day and reversed the
conveyor belt what if he just ran it in
the opposite direction
it would screw the whole thing up right
so by changing the pace of the gut the
speed of the gut the conveyor belt I've
I've ruined this sequence of events and
I spend a lifetime trying to figure out
what's wrong with the parts what's wrong
with the workers what's wrong with the
conveyor belt itself nothing
it's how quickly or slowly it's running
because the motility this peristaltic
activity is affected and once you
supplement for this deficiency and you
return that activity to normal you find
that all of a sudden these strange
allergies eviscerate and all of this gas
and blowing and diarrhea and
constipation and irritability and all of
this inability to equate things that I'm
eating back to what is going on in my
gut seem to go away it's true with all
kinds of conditions you know we we have
subscribed in this world to the fact
that we are so affected by disease and
pathology and once I get you to
to subscribe to the fact that you have a
disease and it can get you to subscribe
to a lifetime of medication
you know this is true in hypertension
you know it's another huge you know we
think genetically inherited disease and
a lot of families have you know
grandfather had high blood pressure
um Dad had high blood pressure now the
sun has high blood pressure so they go
up it's genetic it's genetically
inherited high blood pressure okay well
What gene is being passed down from
these generations to cause this well
they don't know okay well that we know
all of the genes so if we don't know
what Gene it is then let's look at the
methylation genes let's look at the
genes in the human body that refine raw
materials because if you have a certain
deficiency for example in hypertension
very often not always but very often
it's it's caused by elevated levels of
an amino acid called homocysteine you
have in your bloodstream right now I
have it in my bloodstream every listener
to this podcast has homocysteine in
their blood because we in in the process
of normally refining this amino acid
into something called methionine we we
keep this level at a reasonable level
but when you can't break homocysteine
down it rises when homocysteine Rises
it's very irritating
to What's called the endothelial lining
of the blood vessel it in it irritates
the lining of the blood vessel when you
irritate a blood vessel it clamps down
well if you make the pipes smaller in a
fixed system
pressure goes up
you have 63 000 miles of blood vessel in
your body it doesn't take much narrowing
to drive pressure up and so these people
end up with hypertension high blood
pressure and they go to the doctor and
the doctor does an EKG it's normal I
need EG it's normal stress EKG it's
normal cardiac cath normal heart and
lung sounds normal dye contrast study
normal the entire cardiac workout's
normal
and then they still start pounding on
the heart with medication because they
can't figure out why the blood pressure
is up but they never actually looked at
what raw material was missing in their
body not allowing them to bring
homocysteine down and allowing the
vascular system to relax
as the vascular system relaxes pressure
returns to normal
you spent 22 years at that insurance
company yeah looking at the database
that you describe
um and as you as you're saying that you
know much of the sort of medical
profession and I think most of society
yeah and I don't want to attack the
medical person I really you know I mean
no play I am a huge lover and believer
in modern medicine it's saved people
very close to me and trust me if I hit a
windshield at 20 miles an hour I want a
surgeon I want painkillers I'm going to
the ER there's been this kind of this
it's not a preventative approach to
disease that we've taken over the last
couple of decades it really is you know
to put a Band-Aid on something that's
that's emerged and as you said at the
start of this conversation these
predicaments these um diseases emerged
decades before we even see the symptoms
oftentimes
um at the end of your 22 years at the
insurance company you started to look at
these things which you call modifiable
risk factors yes what is a modifiable
risk factor and what are the most common
modifiable risk factors in your view
well I mean one of the most common ones
saw was a modifiable risk factor is it's
a risk factor that you have
and if you changed it it would have
modified it it would have a
demonstrative impact on the trajectory
of your life so for example anemia right
low low hemoglobin low red blood cell
count low oxygen transport in the blood
will exacerbate just about any condition
that you have right so if you are
hypertensive and anemic if you are
diabetic and anemic if you are morbidly
obese and anemic meaning you have low
blood oxygen because you have low red
blood cells low hemoglobin
what if you could modify the anemia
well if you could modify the anemia
carry more oxygen in the blood you'd be
much more resilient to all of these
conditions right so the same thing is
true with dementia and Alzheimer's and
and cognitive function as you impair
cognitive function you increase the
incidence of all cause mortality so a
modifiable risk factor would be
something like
um looking at the levels of vitamin D3
in the blood blood in the body so it's
estimated that roughly 50 percent of the
world's population is clinically
deficient in vitamin D3 why is that
important
um well vitamin D3 is the only vitamin
that a human being can make on our own
there's hundreds of vitamins in your
bloodstream right now you're only
capable of making one and it's vitamin
D3 Cola calciferol we make it from
sunlight and cholesterol you don't even
need to eat to make this vitamin there
is not a single cell in the entire human
body that does not have a receptor site
for this vitamin it also acts like a
hormone it's calcium transport molecule
it's enormously impactful in your immune
system clinical deficiency in vitamin D3
was at one time the second leading cause
of morbidity in covet you know when they
said covid disproportionately affected
minorities if you ever heard that it's
true so how did covet dish
proportionately affect the minorities it
wasn't like the virus didn't start going
after certain minority populations well
it actually did but it wasn't because
they were not minorities that had to do
with the pigment of their skin the
darker the pigmentation of your skin the
lower the vitamin D3 the lower the
vitamin D3 the more compromised the
immune system the more compromised the
immune system the more susceptible you
are to attack that suggests that if you
have darker skin like I do that you
should spend more time in the sunlight
yes it does it absolutely does I mean
you and I just based on our skin tone if
you and I in a pair of board shorts went
out and spent 30 minutes in sunlight I
would manufacture about 25 1000 IU's
international units of vitamin D3 you
would manufacture about 3 500.
it's not fair we can run but you also
you also look better older and you don't
age you don't get wrinkles as much
if there's some trade-offs so so when
you look at you know African-American
populations Latino populations Middle
Eastern populations there the percentage
of vitamin D3 deficiency approaches 85
percent right the truth is most of us
are not getting enough sun it's not that
we're getting too much so let's talk
about the depletion of this one nutrient
can I just ask them before we move on to
the depletion of that nutrient because I
want to understand why that is my guess
was that because people with darker
skins have grown up in sunlight correct
we spent more time in in the sunlight
I'm guessing which meant that we
adjusted our production of vitamin D3 to
suit the environment we lived in yeah
you actually have a better barrier right
you are
um less susceptible to skin down damage
from sunlight than someone with lighter
skin right and so if you actually look
because it used to be a population
mortality expert
um you know the hot the longest life
expectancies
um were centered right around the
equator of the earth if you look at most
of the blue zones they're going to be
sort of closer to the Equator of the
earth they're going to be closer to
places where the sun shines longer
periods of time throughout the year the
blue zones the blue zones are sorry the
blue zones are areas of the world where
people live
um extraordinarily long life
expectancies right Mediterranean diets
so
the longest life expectancies are
centered around the the Equator so for
every 20 degrees
um
latitude because it's just longitude
every 20 degrees latitude there's a
precipitous drop in life expectancy
until you get to the poles
where when I started in this industry a
um the lowest the shortest life
expectancy on earth existed so when I
was born in 1970 a true Eskimo had a
56-year life expectancy 56 years had 56.
true Eskimo so these are these are at
the polls now why because they would go
months without seeing the Sun and when
they did see the sun they were layered
up so they had brittle bone disease they
had autoimmune disease they had
immunocompromised conditions all kinds
of conditions that go with severe
depletion and vitamin D3 and so I would
see this in the medical record all the
time right I would see medical record
after medical records you know patient
has been had a decade or longer of
clinical deficiency in vitamin D3 well
when you deplete this nutrient and you
don't supplement for it by the way
vitamin D3 is so easy to supplement for
everybody should be taking vitamin D3
unless you're getting adequate sunlight
5000 IUS of D3 with 80 micrograms of K2
and you know you you deplete this
nutrient eventually you will develop
rheumatoid r arthritis-like symptoms now
you don't have rheumatoid arthritis but
you have you have the same identical
symptoms when you're depleted in vitamin
D3 you start waking up sore and achy
like you had a workout the night before
when you haven't soles your feet and
your ankles are tender when you get out
of bed in the morning to walk to the
bathroom take your first pee
um your your knees and hips and ankles
start to stiffen up then it goes to
cross the shoulders and eventually it's
hard to make a really tight fist well if
you go to the wrong physician Family
Medicine practitioner that's seeing a
lot of high volume of patients you start
to give them that description they go
you know what you got you've got
rheumatoid arthritis I'm going to hit
you with something called
corticosteroids I'm going to put you on
some prednisone first and then we're
going to transition you to a
corticosteroid look at Methotrexate or
one of these and and you're gonna be
fine you know you know it's going to
push this off into the future well we
knew that if you started corticosteroids
that at first they had an
anti-inflammatory effect but you had
roughly six years in one day until
you're having a joint replacement
because first they're anti-inflammatory
but then they eat the joint like a
termite and so it was so accurate that
if you were a 60 year old female and you
were misdiagnosed with rheumatoid
arthritis because you had a vitamin D3
deficiency I would artificially Advance
your age six years I would schedule a
joint replacement that wasn't required
by the way I'll schedule the joint
replacement and then I would begin to
reduce what's called your ambulatory
profile how well you ambulate how well
you move and we know now that sitting is
the new smoking right sedentary
lifestyle is the leading cause of
all-cause mortality and so as I start to
reduce your ambulatory profile I bring
in all of the diseases that exacerbate
with reduced motility so if I back this
up
you're diagnosed with a condition that
you didn't have
because you had a deficiency in a very
simple nutrient so then you're put on a
medication that wasn't required this
caused you to have surgery that you
didn't need because to replace a joint
that wasn't initially going to be
defective this reduced your mobility and
it brought diseases forward that you
never would have caught and you died
early from a condition you never would
have had because you had deficiency in a
nutrient that was misdiagnosed
mistreated and led to your early demise
and I could give you hundreds of
examples like this and this is why if
you look at the 2016 Harvard study the
2019 Johns Hopkins study
medical error is the third leading cause
of death medical error medical error is
that misdiagnosis misdiagnosis and
medical error
the average American
over 50 52 is on five prescription
medications these are synthetic chemical
Pharmaceuticals right and in a lot of
cases we don't know the long-term side
effects of these in a lot of these cases
we actually don't even know the
mechanism by which they work if you
actually open the PDR that comes the the
disclaimer that comes with a lot of
these medications you'll see that they
say mechanism of action unknown
well it's a sleep medication how does it
make me sleep I don't know just makes
you sleep right in fact most people that
are suffering from from sleep issues are
suffering some sleep issues not because
they can't sleep not because they're not
tired because their mind is keeping them
awake
right if you have a gene mutation called
comt catecholomethyl transferase then
what happens to you is you lay down to
go to sleep
and there's nothing more frustrating
than one spouse having this G mutation
and one knot oh my God I think you're
talking about me and my partner I'm the
one yeah that I need some like sound or
something to go to sleep because yeah
she's just out like a light there you go
see and nothing's more frustrating
because so annoying I sometimes sleep in
another room okay so the reason why
you're not falling asleep is because
when your environment quiets your mind
wakes up and if you actually hone in on
the kind of things you're thinking about
you're thinking about the most innocuous
little nonsense right I mean it's like
did I get everything on my grocery list
uh did my belt match my shoes today
um did I return that email it's nothing
that couldn't wait till the next day 100
yeah and so and sometimes you can even
catch yourself going what am I doing
thinking about the color of dishes I'm
gonna have if I threw a party which I'm
probably not going to throw it's just
like how did I get down this rabbit hole
right and um this is because you know
the you are not quieting the mind at the
pace that you are exciting the mind so
in other words when you lay down and go
to sleep and your environment quiets
your mind starts to wake up so you need
to be distracted so that your mind
doesn't continue to run but if you just
put the right amino acid balance in fact
I would bet my career you have this gene
mutation
I will pay for your test if you don't
it's 599 dollars it's a cheek swab you
do once in your lifetime and it will
tell you if you have this gene mutation
comt and if you do I'll tell you exactly
what supplement to take and it will
become a permanent thing of your past
you take methyl folate and depending on
where the gene break is and how severe
it is you add you may add something
called Sam e s a dinosaur methionine and
these sound like fancy names they're
just fancy names for vitamins and amino
acids there you all of these are in your
bloodstream right now so when you look
at the sequence of breaks that somebody
has then you can tell them exactly what
supplement to take when they take the
supplement their body is no longer
deficient
right deficiencies over time Express
themselves as all kinds of things you
know there's a lot of people that can't
reach elevated emotional states for any
prolonged period of time this is because
mood and emotional states are recipes
just like a you know a chef
makes a recipe but if you went to a
bakery chef and you said you can bake
whatever you want you just can't use
butter
okay it doesn't sound like a big deal
it's just one ingredient but think of
the number of cookies pastries pies
brownies you know then it would affect
it would affect so many different
recipes just by removing one ingredient
this is the same thing that happens in
human beings if you couldn't use
serotonin to assemble mood okay now any
emotional state that requires that
neurotransmitter as a part of its
structure you can Assemble
and as I release that mutation you when
you people hear the term mutation they
think of it as being something that's
happened in me and I'm maybe you know
one of a few that have that mutation
mutation sounds like a yeah it does
sound just doesn't sound like an aliens
yeah it sounds like you know my sister
won't have it and it's just me okay so a
gene mutation means that you know we get
a copy of our genes from each parent
right and then these the the copy of
these genes is passed down to us and we
know you know most of us are familiar
with basic genetics eye color skin color
detached to your lobes
um but there's nothing you can do with
that information
so beyond your ancestry you know whether
you've got Irish heritage or Native
American Indian or what have you I mean
those are if you did a 23 and me you'd
be able to find your ancestry which is
also your genetic history
that's not actionable information
when you look at the genes of
methylation right and there are several
of them I look at five majors and a few
minors when you look at the genes of
methylation these are the genes that
code for how materials are taken into
the body are refined into the usable
form
and these are not mutations that you're
going to suffer from what they do is
they they
cause deficiencies to arise in the body
and it's this deficiency that leads to
the expression of these conditions and
so when you can't adequately methylate
neurotransmitters you have a deficiency
in a certain neurotransmitter any mood
any emotional state that requires that
neurotransmitter you can't assemble if
you have a deficiency in the ability to
quiet the mind then you have excess
neurotransmitters in the brain which
cause it to stay in awakened state so
that Gene that is responsible for my
loud mind when I go to sleep do you have
any idea the amount of people that have
that particular Gene well 44 of the
world's population has a gene mutation
called MTHFR methylene tetrahydrofolate
ductase this is a genetic mutation that
impairs the ability to convert folate
into methylfolate or folic acid into
methylpholate and that might not sound
like a big deal but folic acid is one of
the most prevalent nutrients in the
human diet
and the thing about folic acid is that
folic acid is an entirely man-made
chemical folic acid is not found
anywhere on the surface of the Earth you
can't find folic acid anywhere naturally
in nature and yet we give folic acid
to pregnant women when they get pregnant
because we tell pregnant women that
folic acid prevents neural tube defects
well that's patently false folic acid
doesn't prevent anything folic acid has
to be converted
first into tetralog folate then
dihydrofolate but eventually it becomes
something called methopholate and that
prevents a neural tube defect well what
if like 44 of the population and 44 of
women this woman has this gene mutation
and you give her folic acid the man-made
version of folate and she can't convert
it into methylfolate this is where
postpartum depression develops and you
know I have not seen a single
peer-reviewed published clinical study
linking elevated levels of of
uh hormones in female pregnancy to
postpartum depression but if you give a
woman that can't methylate folic acid
fourteen hundred percent of the daily
allowance of folic acid and she can't
break it down then she goes nuts and
then eventually the pregnancy ends the
depression goes away and so she blames
it on the pregnancy not on the vitamin
and you know we do this over and over
and over again you know we have in in
the modern industrial world we try to
synthesize what occurs naturally in
nature in a laboratory you know there's
three types of B12 right the dinosaur
cobellum and hydroxycobalamin
methylcobalamin these forms of B12 occur
naturally in nature there's one that we
make synthetically in a laboratory it's
called cyanocobalamin we make it from
hydrogen cyanide it is useless in the
human body the human body actually has
to take it and convert it into the
active form of B12 called
hydroxycobalamin and so a lot of times
the supplements that we're taking us are
causing more harm than good and we're
taking them because a doctor said well
I'm pregnant my OB GYN told me to take
this synthetic chemical called folic
acid which it's always Beyond me why
anyone would think that something that
we make in a laboratory that's entirely
synthetic that isn't natural that isn't
found anywhere on the surface the Earth
could ever be required for Optimal
Health I mean just in it's on its
surface that sounds
strange to me but
you know yet we do and we don't
understand this process of methylation
so if you once you understand where your
genetic mutations are where the genetic
inability to refine raw materials is you
can go about supplementing targeted
supplementing for that deficiency so you
would recommend people take a genetic
test to find out these answers right I'd
recommend
everyone take that test once in their
lifetime you know I I I'm in the camp
that we're as humans we're not broken
like we totally agree with you you know
what I mean and so whenever there's
something going on in my body or you
know a way that I am or a habit I have
that I'm like why do I do that I'm
always trying to figure out the sort of
I guess the ancestral reason why that
might have helped me to survive or
what's going on so when I hear mutation
it sounds a little bit like broken to me
yeah yeah so I shouldn't use it I mean
we use the term mutation but basically
you know in our ancestry right we pass
on our entire genetic code which a lot
of that is hair color eye color skin
color
um you know our Our Heritage but we also
pass on how our body refines certain raw
materials and it's not to say that it's
good or poor or bad or or broken or
fixed but there are certain
um families and human beings that have
an inability to refine certain raw
materials and if we could be aware of
this it is astounding what happened
happens to human beings when you just
give their body the raw material to do
its job you know lots of people that
have attention deficit disorder have
trouble sleeping will are also have a
trouble with prioritization they just
don't know it they'll say things like I
work really well under pressure right
most entrepreneurs say I work really
well under pressure do you say that oh
my God okay so I only work when there is
pressure okay so I was that kid in
school that would only do the test when
you know there was an hour left to go or
you know the homework or whatever yeah
so many entrepreneurs are that way and
and when you say you work really well
under pressure physiologically what
you're saying is I lack the ability to
set priorities internally so I use
external pressure to set my priorities
and why is that it's because when you
don't have the right methylated
nutrients in the body you lend equal
weight to every thought that comes into
your mind all right so you could be
working on uh you know the deal the
joint venture business closing of a
Lifetime right and you got the contract
and you have of 45 minutes to get it
back to your lawyer you know the deal is
permanently going to go away this is a
life-changing deal you've waited for
this your entire life it's a very
meaningful event you're working your way
through this legal document and you look
over at your phone and there's an
Instagram and you're like oh that's my
neighbor's cousin's kid
fishing in a lake you know I wonder if
he catches a fish
so you start looking at it and you like
see still casting oh he didn't catch it
that time now meanwhile this has gone
from 45 minutes to 35 minutes
and now it's down to 25 minutes and all
of a sudden you go oh you know grab you
turn the phone off which didn't mean
anything anyway and you focus all of
your attention and because you're very
intelligent and you and you execute and
you can hyper Focus you hyper focus on
this and you warm your way through it
and one minute before the deadline you
hit the send button lawyer gets it the
deal goes through and you go
I work really well under pressure
what's that called that process you
described there is many people describe
it as procrastination it's
procrastination but it's procrastination
because you give equal weight to all of
these different variants that come into
your and that come into your your field
so you can actually give equal priority
to very disequal events but also you
know sometimes if I'm looking at that
contract the contract clause is a little
bit difficult and my attempt to maybe
just Escape discomfort would be I'd go
do the dishes right and so I had an
erail on the podcast he wrote a book
called indestructible and he says we're
creatures that we're not pleasure
seeking creatures we're creatures that
are avoiding discomfort essentially I
think that aging
is the aggressive pursuit of comfort
could not agree with you more
let's use Dana White as an example okay
because you know the reason why I came
across your work is because of a clip
that
you know involved Dana White and I'm
sure you I know you get this a lot
because I've seen you um be asked about
this in interviews but for context for
anybody listening I don't know where I
was or ah now I know what happened my
friend sent into a WhatsApp group a clip
of Dana White talking about you and
that's the clip that made me
go down the rabbit hole oh I watched
that clip I then did some research I
then watched a series of videos of you
online talking about health and I
watched you asking audience members to
stand up and name the pr you know the
health issue they were suffering and you
on the spot told them what was missing
from their their life their diet
whatever it might have been you kind of
diagnosed them in a way of
um and then I reached out to you on
Instagram and that's why you're here but
if we go back to the start of that it
was that story that Dana White told that
had me so compelled to reach out to you
for anybody that doesn't know and there
will be some people that don't know Dana
White is the president of the UFC which
is the the the big fighting tournament
where everybody kicks each other's heads
in so what's your take on the Dana White
story so Dana White is a an example I
mean he's just a celebrity example but
he is a shining example of the vast
number of people you know men and women
in his age category that that have given
up on the capacity to thrive they've
accepted that they have hypothyroid
hypertension they wake up sore and achy
in the mornings that they don't have a
response to exercise they have a little
bit of spare tire their brain foggy
they're on three or four medications in
his case he was on seven medications at
the time three of which were for blood
pressure
um he was on you know I think a thyroid
medication was also on he's been very
public about this by the way and and
again I have to say I'm not licensed to
practice medicine so it was my clinical
team that came up with a diagnosis and I
communicated it to Dana
um I do train Physicians to read blood
work and genetic testing but I can't
practice medicine but the the point is
that when I met Dana
all he wanted to do was for me to
predict his life expectancy and I hadn't
done that in almost seven years I left
out in industry for a reason I don't do
it anymore the test that I do does not
predict life expectancy the genetic test
and the blood work that I do will not
tell you how long you're going to live I
have no interest in predicting death
anymore I only have an interest in
extending life and you know when when
Dana was only interested in me
predicting his death so I said okay for
Dana White I'll come out I'll meet with
you
I'll do a blood test on you a gene test
on you I'll pull all your medical
records and I'll give you your life
expectancy
but what I did was went out and got his
blood work in his Gene test and
um I was actually in bed
at 1 30 in the morning when the lab was
running his blood work and I've had
seven life-threatening alert calls um in
the middle of the night because when you
drop blood work off at the lab the lab
runs it through the night if they find a
life-threatening alert they call the
account holder right so I own the
company I was on the account so LabCorp
calls us at one o'clock 1 30 in the
morning says hey we have a
life-threatening alert on a patient I
was like whoa
um what's the patient's name they said
last name is white I said Dana White and
they said yeah Nick wow what's the
life-threatening alert they said
triglycerides are almost 800.
now triglycerides a measure of blood fat
okay it shouldn't be above 149. at 200
or 300 this is a cataclysmic level in
the blood especially in a fasted State
okay we pull this blood in a fasted
State they weren't 400 they weren't 500
they weren't 600 they weren't 700 they
were like 768.
so they were I mean this is an enormous
number and so I said okay uh I need to
get the blood work over to the you know
to the doctor when they sent the
um the blood work into the portal I then
saw that he was insulin resistant he was
hyperinsulinemic he was pre-diabetic he
had skyrocketing levels of cholesterol
he had he was hyper triglyceridemic he
was hyper
um homocystinemic this homocysteine that
I told you elevates and causes the blood
vessels to constrict
um I mean he had all of these conditions
I literally at that moment booked a
flight
for 7 30 or 8 30 in the morning
to head out and see him and
um because I said I need to go see him
in person and I remember I think his
assistant called me and I was at the
airport and she said hey Dina wants to
know if he's life expectancy is in I go
well I'm on my way to see him you know
um and she goes oh God is it like that I
said yeah it's like that and so I flew
out to see him and I sat down with Dana
and
when we talked about the blood work I
didn't even explain the levels I
explained the symptom
um I did not know that he was on a CPAP
machine but I said I am surprised that
you can actually sleep through the night
because he was so hypoxic
um red blood cell count hemoglobin
levels I'm surprised he could even sleep
through the night without like just
waking up choking gagging he's like dude
I'm a CPAP machine I wake up every night
I throw up in the middle of the night I
throw up so much I'm losing my voice
um and I said this level of claudication
triglycerides in the bloodstream I'm
surprised you can't even bend down
entire shoes that it's not painful to
tie your shoes not that it's not
restrictive to tie your shoes it's not
painful like it doesn't feel like the
Skin's going to peel off your legs and
he went what the [__]
slammed his hand down he was like how
did you you know how did you know that
and I said Dana your level of brain fog
and fatigue right now has got to be at a
crushing level of fatigue I don't know
how the only thing getting you through
the day is your own stubborn willpower
and I'm surprised you can remember
anything from one minute to the next and
his whole staff was like dude he's so
forgetful he passes out in meetings he's
sleeping in the planes he's gagging
snoring
um these were not things I necessarily
knew about him so I began to describe
all the outcomes of these kinds of
conditions and I said look
um if if you don't do what we're going
to ask you to do for the next 10 weeks
you know based on this blood work and
the medical records that we pulled for
the previous 10 years and the
demographic data we pulled for 10 years
you have a life expectancy at 10.4 years
um you know for a 52 year old man to
realize that he's not going to make it
out of his 60s a big realization and he
flicked a switch a level of discipline
that you know I haven't seen in a
patient a long time he goes dude I'll do
whatever you tell me to do so we wrote a
prescription ketogenic diet I I'm a fan
of the keto diet I don't think everybody
needs to be on the keto diet but
um by prescription ketogenic diet we
wrote a keto diet right down to the
grocery list keto reset diet and I said
if it's literally if it's not on here
you can't eat it Dana this is your
grocery list you go to the store you buy
this you send your Chef to the store to
buy this you make this if it's not this
recipe if it's not on here you literally
can't eat it your only leeway is water
and the supplements and um and we
started a process of balancing hormones
controlling his glycemic index of using
amino acids to bring down his level of
homocysteine to actually try to fix the
insulin resistance to reduce this
triglycerides
and in 10 weeks he had a such a material
change in his blood work I forget how
much weight he lost I think he had lost
almost 28 or 30 pounds at times he's
over 40 pounds now
um by the end of the fifth month he was
completely off of every prescription
medication he was on he's down 44 pounds
he lost you know he's no longer using
the CPAP machine he no longer is
pre-diabetic he no longer has insulin
resistance he no longer has
life-threatening levels of triglyceride
in fact they're normal his kidney
function improved his liver function
improved his immune system strengthened
he feels like a 35 year old man again
his skin tone all improved um blood
pressure returned to normal he's not on
any blood pressure medication so his
blood pressure returns normal and he was
like
Jude I had no idea I could feel this
good I feel freaking amazing and his
life expectancy
almost tripled
almost triples tripled just under 30
years
when I heard the story about Dana White
and I saw he had gone from respectfully
being a man that had a little bit of
weight to having this these six pack abs
on Instagram of course the six-pack
isn't the the outcome is as you've said
it's the stuff going on inside here
that's really the transformation
it left me with the question like okay I
heard the keto a bit but what can
someone who's just heard that at home
where do they start with getting
extending their life by triple and
getting the
so you know he also started something
called the Superhuman protocol and
superhuman protocols using magnetism
oxygen and light right so the only
things that we really get from Mother
Nature the the big benefit we get from
Mother Nature is we get magnetism from
the earth we get oxygen from the air we
get light from the sun the truth is most
of us are not contacting the surface of
the Earth that much anymore so he bought
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
worth of equipment a pmf mat an oxygen
what's called a hypermax oxygen to do
exercise with oxygen therapy and a red
light therapy bed and I had him use that
equipment every single day seven days a
week
but if your listeners want to do it for
free
you can take off your shoes and contact
the surface of the Earth and I'm talking
about bare feet on soil dirt grass sand
because earthing and grounding is a very
real thing we actually discharge into
the Earth we actually human beings build
up a charge do you know that pH the acid
alkaline scale pH stands for potential
hydrogen it's a charge it's a complete
fallacy that you can get alkaline by
drinking alkaline water that's the
biggest marketing myth ever sold to the
public but you can get alkaline by
contacting the surface of the Earth so
if you don't have 150 Grand which I
don't expect anybody listening to this
podcast to spend 150 Grand but he did I
said you need a magn you need a pmf mat
so you can be alkaline you need to spend
10 minutes a day breathing
um 95 O2 under mild exercise and you
need to lay in a red light therapy bed
so in the absence of the Superhuman
protocol you can become superhuman by
contacting the Earth and by learning to
do breath work
let's talk about breath work I spend
eight minutes every day doing a very
specific series of breath work and I'll
teach it to you now you said your wife
has certified him yeah my partner she's
a she's a breath Butler
um I've done breath work with I've done
breath work with a few people but no
one's ever had the profound impact on me
through breath work that she has I've
never shouted her out before so I
probably should her Instagram is at
m-e-l-o-ai for anybody that's interested
in breath work people do not realize the
power of something that is so accessible
so free and so easy to do right they
they want things to be more complicated
but it's not and when I said the
presence of oxygen is the absence of
disease it's absolutely true remember
that every elevated emotional state that
a human being can experience actually
has in its molecular structure
oxygen is a component of that emotion so
if you look at the difference between
passion Elation Joy arousal libido and
anger for example it's usually only one
neurotransmitter and the presence of
oxygen the reason why no human being has
ever woken up laughing is because you
don't have the oxidative state to
experience laughter right out of deep
sleep but can you wake up angry yes
because anger doesn't require oxygen so
every morning contact the surface of the
Earth and then spend eight minutes doing
I do a Wim Hof style breath work I give
credit where credit's due he's the
father of breath work as far as I'm
concerned so I do three rounds of 30
deep breaths
like obnoxiously deep breaths and I
start by trying to take my belly button
and pull my belly button out towards the
wall imagine there's a string pulling
your belly button towards the wall
and then you you fill from the lobes of
the lung to the apex of the lung and
then you exhale and just relax
God knows what they think we're doing
out there
outside this podcast they're like a
bunch of freak I knew it was a cult
um I knew he was a cult leader but um so
you do three rounds of 30 breasts on the
30th breath you exhale and you hold
allow the carbohydrate receptor to reset
when you don't feel you can hold anymore
you take a deep breath in
you hold again and you let it out slope
and you start again I would suggest that
you start with three rounds of five
press then work to 10 15 20 25 and 30.
if you get lightheaded this is a good
sign that the oxygen tension is changing
in your brain if your fingers and toes
get tingly this is a good sign that
you're changing the oxygen tension if
you feel some kind of heat uh
temperature change in your neck these
are all Great Signs you will get to the
point where you can actually hold your
breath for two or three minutes
sometimes four minutes between rounds of
breath work
um and then the last thing is to expose
yourself to natural sunlight first thing
in the morning the first 45 minutes of
the day God gives us a very very special
type of light it's called First Light
there's no UVA there's no UVB rays in
this light
um so that's not the damaging race from
the Sun it still generates vitamin D3 it
has a positive effect on cortisol on
vitamin D3 first light is the best way
to reset your circadian rhythm so by
contacting the surface of the Earth
doing breath work and getting first
light you can get to the same place that
Dana White did with 150 Grand in
equipment what about oxygen masks
because I I'll be honest when I read
when I read um about the Dana story I
went on Amazon soon after and I was like
I'm just gonna buy an oxygen canister
good idea bad idea
um so what you want to do is um you know
you get an oxygen concentrator which
takes 21 oxygen from which is what the
concentration at sea level it turns it
into 95 O2 and it fills this bag and it
can refill this bag over and over and
over again okay I use one called the
hypermax you see it on my Instagram and
um you turn you plug it in you turn it
on it fills this bag and then you go in
you put an oxygen mask on and you
exercise for 10 minutes only 10 minutes
cycle for three minutes uh Sprint for 30
seconds cycle for three minutes print
for 30 seconds cycle three minutes
Sprint 30 seconds and you're done and
what this does is it raises something
called the partial pressure of the
storage of oxygen in your blood the only
two time two-time Noble Laureate Prize
winner in Medicine Dr Otto Warburg won
both of his Nobel prizes for his work
and exercise with oxygen therapy you
want to be a superhuman do mild exercise
every day while breathing 95 O2 it's
important that you're exercising and
then after that you move into a red
light therapy bed photo biomodulation
um so you know if you don't have access
to a hypermax oxygen machine just do the
breath work get the breath in you know
exchange the oxygen tension and the
tissues and expose yourself to First
Light what about cold cold water
cleansing so I'm a huge fan of cold
water punching but probably not for the
reasons why you think you know um I also
sit on the board of the NFL
um Alumni Association athletica as a
health services director you know there
was a time when we used to think that
putting athletes in cold water after
exercise was good because of its
anti-inflammatory effects we know now
that that's only about 15 of the benefit
the majority of the benefit comes from
something called a cold shock protein if
you really want to be fascinated Google
cold shock proteins these are reserved
proteins that are in your liver they're
dumped into the bloodstream in effort to
save your life when you put yourself in
cold water they scour the body of free
radical oxidation they increase the rate
of protein synthesis muscle repair they
are free you get them when you put
yourself in cold water I don't know what
the Celsius conversion is but I use 50
degrees for three minutes minimum six
minutes maximum cold yes it's it's
actually not that cold I mean you know I
see people getting in 37 38 degree water
there's no evidence that I've read that
shows that colder is better you get a
peripheral vasoconstriction so it forces
all the oxygen into the core and up to
the brain um and you ask you get an
activation of something called Brown fat
Right thermogenesis comes from Brown fat
and for the women that are listening for
some reason I seem to ensnare the women
when I say this remember that the
definition of a calorie is a measure of
heat right I mean the definition of a
calorie is the amount of energy it takes
to raise one cubic centimeter of water
one degree Centigrade so if if a calorie
is a measure of heat then this means
that when Heat's leaving your body
calories are leaving your body so if
there is nothing nothing no amount of
exercise hits cardio no type of
cardiovascular or weight training that
comes anywhere close to immersing
yourself in cold water in terms of what
will strip fat off your body fast if you
want to strip that off your body
getting cold water three to six minutes
a day
that's fascinating because because the
oxygen rushes to my head that's why it
has a really profound impact on mood
that's why it has a very profound impact
on mood because if you think about it
what's the reason why we need deep sleep
what happens in deep Sleep that's so
special there's a secondary oxygen
transfer we transfer oxygen from the
periphery from the extremities to the
brain remember the brain's a
non-metabolic organ
so in other words it's unlike a muscle
if I pick up a weight and start to work
out my muscle on my arm my body will
send more blood more amino acids more
oxygen to that muscle because it's
working well if I'm sitting at my
computer and I'm watching reruns of The
Simpsons or I'm sitting in my computer
and I'm solving the most complex joint
venture agreement partnership agreement
with all kinds of mathematical equations
my brain gets the same amount of
nutrients same amount of blood flow same
amount of oxygen so it eats the same
meal whether or not it's in a dead
Sprint or whether or not it's just
chilling on the couch except in deep
sleep and when you're in cold water
because it's forcing the oxygen up to
the brain you said earlier about
um about Comfort yes I I was speaking to
someone yesterday about this thing
called he referred to it as the Comfort
crisis and how you know as we've become
more Civ I would say civilized but I
don't know if that's the right
terminology as we've become more
advanced technologically as humans we
can make our lives increasingly more
comfortable correct sounds like a good
thing terrible it's accelerates Aging in
every form I mean aging is the
aggressive pursuit of comfort we have
got to stop telling Grandma not to go
outside it's too hot not to go outside
it's too cold just to lay down just to
relax to eat at the very first Pang of
hunger this is collapsing all of our own
natural defense mechanisms you know if
we don't load our bones they don't
strengthen if you don't tear a muscle it
doesn't grow if you don't challenge the
immune system it weakens
and so stress is very often very good
for the body thermal stress
um you know weight-bearing exercise
breath work these things put stressors
into the body that are very they have a
very positive effect that's
strengthening you we want to regulate
everything now we regulate our
temperature we go from a you know uh
temperature controlled office to a
temperature controlled car to a
temperature controlled home
um you know we don't we don't thermal
regulate anymore I mean you know usually
when you when I ask people to start
taking cold showers they take their
first cold shower they never do it again
why because they don't want to be
uncomfortable
and so when you learn to deal
and become comfortable with being
uncomfortable this is like a metaphor
for life it's almost like yoga if you've
ever done really intense yoga and you're
holding a yoga pose and you're you're
trying to remain calm and focus on your
breath while your body's in intense pain
now you're not in any risk but your ass
feels like it's going to peel off your
legs and your hamstrings are firing and
you're sweating and you're shaking and
you're doing this thing that's called
the Candlestick but it's really painful
and if you can mean maintain calm and
and and breathe through a situation like
that what happens four hours later when
you get a nasty Instagram message
nothing doesn't shift your mood and if
we don't learn to control our emotional
state we will never control our future
you know MIT did an incredible clinical
study that showed that the amygdala of
the brain which is where we experience
emotion
is the soul gateway to an area of the
brain called the hippocampus which is
where we hold our memories
so just imagine that the emotional
center of the brain is the soul gateway
to the memory of the brain this is why
if you've ever had an argument with your
spouse you can always recall with
Incredible accuracy every other time
they've made you feel this way you know
you did this on September 21st you did
this when we were on the boat with my
boys you did this and
um you know our Christmas holiday party
for Christmases ago because because that
emotion is linked to that memory so you
can recall that memory very accurately
well our memory our hippocampus is what
projects into the prefrontal cortex it
determines our future it's our
conscience
so this means if emotion is the only
gateway to memory and memory projects to
our conscience with our which is our
future this means that your current
emotional state
determines your future
that's a biophysiologic fact
so like for example if you had an
argument with your spouse on the way to
work and you get out of the car and you
slam the door and you walk into the
office when you break the plane of the
door of that office the only memories
you can recall about the office at that
moment are negative
you're gonna walk through the door of
the office you'll be like they don't
respect me around here I'm going to have
a Stern talking to management today you
know my office better you know you know
nobody better be my desk and you know
what Mary better not run into me today
because she doesn't respect me you can
just start going through all the
negative things about the office office
that do anything to you how do I change
your mind you learn to control your
emotion how well first you start by
putting the right nutrients into the
body that allows you to achieve elevated
emotional states
learn to do things like when you feel
like you are beginning to lose control
of your emotional state you you you
actually break that cycle I usually do
it with breath work
um and so
um you know first it begins by having
the right raw materials but this is just
taking you back to the coal plunge if
you can start your day in an elevated
emotional state if anybody listening to
this has ever really done a cold plunge
tell me if you were ever in a bad mood
getting out of a cold punch just try to
be in a bad mood getting out of a
co-punch they say if you want to cure
depression push somebody in cold water
you know
um and it's so true you're in such an
elevated emotional state you're like wow
now you go cruising into the day and get
a little negative you know Instagram
message and your you know spouse calls
you and tells you she forgot what you
wanted to get at the grocery store and
you get to work and you got a little
problem at the office these things roll
off your back instead of Shifting your
stay which now shifts your memory which
now changes the trajectory of your
prefrontal cortex which affects your
future
I do a lot of traveling Gary I travel
all over the world all the time awesome
my favorites yeah you travel a lot tons
you've got a bit of a system for
traveling because when I travel I feel
like [__] oh I feel amazing when I
travel when I post all about it on my
Instagram you know all I do is teach on
Instagram but you know I went Miami
Atlanta New York London stodd
Switzerland to buy to buy Miami Miami
Vegas I got I I got up at four o'clock
this morning to come here I mean I
landed here at I think 7 15 this morning
and you're flying out of here I'm flying
out of here now in five minutes I'm
finally out here in five minutes and I'm
going on a red eye back to Miami
and you feel good when you travel and I
feel like [__] what do you think we're
doing differently if you were to guess
okay so there's three things that that
you can do when you travel and first and
foremost and I don't know why anybody
talks about this is that you know
everybody talks about waking with the
sun which I'm a big believer in
um or forcing yourself to stay up to try
to get onto a new time zone when you
change time zones the single most
important thing that you can do is
preserve your sleeping window do not eat
during your normal sleeping window let
me tell you what I mean let's say that
you're on the East Coast you live in New
York
um and you go to bed at 10 and you get
up at 6 A.M okay you would have been at
10 p.m get up at 6 a.m most people go to
bed at midnight get up at 6 a.m so let's
say you go to bed Ten you get up 6 a.m
and now you go to London okay so now
London is depending on the time of the
year six hours ahead
if you eat
during 10 P.M to 6 a.m New York time
there is zero chance you will adjust to
that time zone we are more tied to our
digestion in terms of our circadian
rhythm than we are to the sleep wake
cycle of the Sun so in other words if I
fly to London and I start eating when
it's 3 30 in the morning my time
my body goes what the heck are you doing
we're having steak and eggs and a
champagne it's 3 30 in the morning right
your circadian rhythm is screwed up so
shift your sleeping window and preserve
that sleeping window in your new time
zone and do not eat during those times
so in other words in London that would
be
um 6 a.m to noon so between 6 a.m and
noon I'm not going to eat I'll have
coffee or I'll have water or fluids but
I will not start to eat until noon and
for how long do I preserve that well
depending on how long you're going to be
there usually I'm only if you're there a
week or less preserve your sleeping
window the entire week with your hair
when you're there for more than seven to
ten days then you need to really adjust
to that time zone what happens
physiologically if I don't if you don't
you will you will irrevocably mess up
your circadian rhythm I mean just leave
just just just imagine it so let's say
you lived in New York and you didn't
travel you go to bed at 10 and you wake
up at 6 a.m try for three nights sitting
for 3 30 in the morning get up need a
big breakfast at 3 30 and try to go back
to bed and watch what happens to your
sleep cycle right you'll destroy it so
we don't we preserve our sleeping window
the other thing is I fast on domestic
flights I don't care what time or where
I'm going if I fly anywhere in the
continental United States I fast on
airplanes so I I allow myself
um you know water I hydrate and I have
black coffee on international flights I
just came back from Dubai it was 16
hours I ate on that plane
um and then for flights that are more
than an hour every hour on the hour I
get up out of my seat I don't care how
weird it looks I go to the back of the
plane I do 25 air squats I go either
into the bathroom or in the back of the
plane I do 25 deep breaths
on a 10 hour flight I'll do 250
depressing 250 air squats over the
course of a 10 hour
um flight you feel amazing and then I
eat fats and proteins on flights
carbohydrates at altitude are terrible
for you and it's usually where all the
salt hides remember that you know
there's there are essential fatty acids
meaning they're essential for life
there's two of them
um if you don't get these fatty acids
you'll die there's nine essential amino
acids they're proteins they're essential
for life if you don't get these nine
essential amino acids you'll die there
is no such thing as an essential
carbohydrate
why why are Cobbs so bad in their
um carbs are bad in the air because as
soon as you divert blood from your brain
to digestion let's not forget it's a 30
foot long tube the higher the the
consumption of carbohydrate the more
blood floods to your gut so you're going
to feel like crying so now you're seated
and your gut is flooded with blood it's
all come from your brain so now you're
tired you're not focused you're
exhausted and you're seated so you're
this isn't a good place to be tired
because you're not going to get good
sleep
right so I said a huge priority on
energy energy is a huge priority to me
so when I look at food I look at it two
ways it's going to serve me it's going
to steal from me when I'm flying first
class back to Miami tonight it's a red
eye I'm gonna actually use that time to
sleep I'm not going to waste it on
eating because I know that I'm first of
all I'm past my feeding window now
because I preserve my East Coast time
feeding window and this is what keeps
your the train running on time what is
energy you said energy there what is it
energy energy is oxygen in your blood
everything that you perceive about
energy is nothing more than oxygen in
your blood if you told me Gary I had a
lot of energy today physiologically what
you're saying is I had a lot of oxygen
in my blood today
oxygen equals energy
at the start of this conversation I
asked you a question I said why should
people listen to your message we're now
at the end of the conversation what have
I missed that is pertinent important to
your message that we haven't discussed
you know I feel like I could talk about
this forever yeah like to me I feel like
the podcast is just getting going
um you know I I I I believe in human
beings and and and the ability of the
body to heal itself I believe in the
power of the mind and frequency and the
power of this to heal this
um I guess my my message would be and I
don't think that you've missed anything
my message would be that Optimal Health
is found in the basics
not in the complicated fancy
neurotropics or some rare root that's
buried deep in the Amazon jungle it's
found in the basics the further we get
away from the basics magnetism oxygen
light Whole Foods the more unhealthy we
become
and you know my message what I try to
teach on Instagram and what the message
that I get to the world is you know not
that you need a lot of fancy equipment
sure if you can afford it you can have
it but if you get back to the basics of
Mother Nature and back to the basics
with you know our foods good
rule of thumb is if your
great-grandmother wouldn't recognize it
don't eat it
um then you'll find a state of Optimal
Health that's beyond anything that you
thought imaginable there's a superhuman
inside of everybody listening to this
podcast
Gary we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're asking it for the question
that's been left for you is what is the
unobvious thing
that you struggle with
hmm
what is the unobvious thing that I
struggle with you know I
I believe that
I'm so committed to my craft
and I'm so committed to being authentic
that I struggle sometimes like everyone
else when I
I have an extra burden of guilt whenever
I want to just to have any kind of
marginal enjoyment right like if I just
want to have a cocktail or I want to eat
some birthday cake
um which I know is not going to hurt me
and it's not
um you know it's not going to throw me
off but I I really struggle with that I
feel like I'm letting the whole world
down when I do that
um and I know that it's not and it's
ridiculous and you shouldn't be that you
know being that discipline actually
music you know it's not sustainable over
over a longer period of time
um I think that like a lot of people
listening to this podcast I I'm I'm very
hard on myself on My Own Worst Enemy
sometimes
and I have an insatiable appetite to do
what I'm doing and I think kind of I
just wasn't so hard on myself I
probably would find it a lot easier
thank you so much everybody listening to
this you go check out 10x Health um much
of the information you've discussed here
lives within that ecosystem and your
Instagram and your website and those
channels which I've explored you know in
in depth are incredible resources to
understand how to start your journey to
living a more healthy life and that's
that's everything that you you espouse
you're incredible Gary thank you so much
it's very very rare that I find someone
online I then DM them and I nag join DM
for a couple of months to get you here
but but I think everybody listening to
this can understand why
um you're doing incredible work an
incredibly important work an incredibly
important time to shift a narrative and
as I said to you I think before we start
recording or in an interval I realize
that this is literally just the start
for you in the journey in the mission
that you're on yeah it's so clear to me
um thank you I feel the same way
[Music]
I've now been a huel drinker for about
four years roughly so much so that I
ended up investing in the company and I
play a role on the board of the company
but they also very kindly sponsored this
podcast and to be honest I've never said
this before but he all believed in this
podcast before anybody else the CEO
Julian
um told me before we even launched the
podcast how successful it would be and
that heal would back it and I absolutely
have a huge amount of gratitude for them
for that support but an even greater
sense of gratitude for the fact that
they've helped me stay nutritionally
complete throughout the chaos and
hecticness of my tremendously busy
business schedule so if you haven't
tried out here which I hope most of you
have at least given it a go by now try
it out it's an unbelievable way to try
and stay nutritionally on course if you
have a hectic busy schedule and let me
know what you think send me a tweet and
a DM tag me let me know what you think
[Music]
oh